juliaca ciudad del sur de Perú cerca de
la frontera con Bolivia
es el nuevo epicentro de los violentos
enfrentamientos entre la policía y los
manifestantes que exigen la renuncia de
la presidenta Dina boluarte el cierre
del Congreso y la liberación del
expresidente Pedro Castillo quien
intentó disolver el congreso el 7 de
diciembre mientras este se reunía a
discutir su destitución por
señalamientos de corrupción y cuya
reactivación después de una tregua de
fin de año deja decenas de Muertos
al gobierno central de que cómo es
posible que podamos tener tantos
fallecidos los manifestantes denuncian
que están sufriendo el uso del exceso de
la fuerza por parte de la policía y en
estado indefensión
policial que se pone de rodillas
apuntando
[Música]
unos cuatro pasos de esos cuatro pasos
porque no podía el gobierno peruano
respondió restringiendo la entrada de
varios ciudadanos bolivianos
entre ellos el ex presidente Evo Morales
a quienes acusa de promover y participar
en las manifestaciones la
superintendencia
de Evo Morales y de varios de sus
partidarios por afectar directamente las
normas de Perú concretamente el artículo
48 de esta ley la Organización de
Estados Americanos y la Corte
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos ya
han condenado la represión de las
fuerzas estatales de Perú contra los
manifestantes